die schuld von alec baldwin er hat die
tragischen todes schüsse abgegeben auf
seine kamerafrau ein tragischer unfall
ja aber das polizeiprotokoll erlegt das
chaos am filmset jetzt offen und es ist
auch prinz chaos denn er war ja auch der
produzent des films vor allem in sachen
sicherheit ging es chaotisch am set zu
hier sehen wir das polizeiprotokoll
besonders krass darin die zeugenaussagen
des zweiten kameramanns russell lied
denn darin heißt es hier in dem
protokoll ried weiß ich nicht sicher
warum die waffe abgefeuert wurde hier
sehen wir den auszug und hörte nur einen
lauten knall und er sagte auch aus
nachdem die waffe abgefeuert worden war
erinnerte er sich dass joel blutete der
regisseur und halina sagte dass sie ihre
beine nicht mehr spüren
ried gab an dass sich sanitäter um ihre
blutende verletzungen kümmerten als sie
auf dem boden des gebäudes lag das ganze
fand ja am drehort in einer kirche statt
ja und über diese details aus den
polizeiprotokollen und über das was
möglicherweise alec baldwin noch
erwarten muss möglicherweise auch
juristisch darüber wollen wir sprechen
jetzt mit unserem us korrespondenten mit
herbert bauernebel hallo herbert
hallo grüße nach berlin täuscht der
eindruck oder schnürt sich so ein
bisschen das alles zur und umwelt wenn
muss er möglicherweise eben damit
rechnen dass er ja auch dafür belangt
wird dass er eben doch schuld trägt und
er nicht sozusagen derjenige ist er das
tragische opfer auch dieser geschichte
hier festzustellen ist hier in santa fe
natürlich zum einen dass sich die
polizei ermittlungen hier intensivieren
ich selbst habe bei der einfahrt zu
dieser bonanza creek ranch diesem
gelände wo es zum tödlichen schuss
gekommen ist zwei fahrzeuge gesehen
binnen fünf minuten die da hinein
gefahren sind man sieht hier dass das
sheriff department dass die die polizei
hier mit hochdruck ermittelt und
natürlich gibt es immer wieder diese
neuen details die natürlich für alec
baldwin ein großes problem werden
könnten besonders auch die leute die er
offensichtlich angestellt hat oder er
zugelassen hat dass sie angestellt war
darunter eben der regieassistent es
wurde jetzt bekannt dass der im jahr
2009 10 von einem anderen film gefeiert
wurde er hätte sich dort aufgeführt da
barisch was gegenüber von mitarbeitern
und noch wichtiger ist hätte sich dort
ein schuss gelöst aus einer requisiten
was eigentlich sehr ähnlich dem vorfall
der jetzt die ganze welt erschüttert hat
das ist die eine entwicklung die andere
ist dass es aus ermittlerkreisen heißt
das amt aa am tatort am filmset patronen
gefunden wurden die außerhalb der
packung waren die nicht verpackt waren
darunter eben scharfe munition und und
platzpatronen das alles durcheinander
das zeigt eben welche chaotische
zustände hier geherrscht haben am 7
immer wieder wird jetzt auch baldwins
haltung zum thema waffen thematisiert
wie genau ist er seine haltung
alec baldwin vertritt eine muss man
sagen für einen liberalen doch
grundsätzlich moderatere haltung er ist
er gesteht den menschen ein dass sie
waffen haben dürfen allerdings
erforderte mehrmals dass es dafür
einfach strengere regeln geben müsse
beim kauf von waffen an gebrauch von
waffen er sagt es müssen hier strengere
lizenzierungen geben eben ein
kontrollmechanismen die verhindern dass
hier missbrauch betrieben wird er hat
das verglichen etwa mit medikamenten die
man sich ja auch in einer apotheke holen
musste ein arzt verschreiben muss jetzt
natürlich ist die ironie klar dass alec
baldwin selbst der produzent war einer
filmproduktion war wirklich chaotische
und schockierende zustände geherrscht
haben uns den hier gerade nach ihre
gärten sprichst entschuldige herbert wir
sehen hier gerade ein älteres zitat
eingeblendet von alec baldwin im
gespräch damals mit piers morgan bei
siena hat er diesen satz hier gesagt
oder diese sätze gesagt genau das was du
gerade mit deinen worten beschrieben
hast als er gesteht den leuten schon zu
dass sie waffen besitzen dürfen aber
erfordert da eben in diesem cnn gespräch
eindeutig härtere
kontrollmechanismen also der letzte satz
ist der wichtige sollte gründlich
geprüft werden ob jemand eine waffe
haben davon da machen sich eben jetzt
viele drüber auch lustig unter anderem
donald trump junior der sagt also so ist
es mit alec baldwin auf der einen seite
fordert der schärfe kontrolle doch auf
der anderen seite dann solch ein chaos
bei ihm am set
ja natürlich donald trump junior der
sohn des ehemaligen präsidenten ist
praktisch ein fürsprecher der waffen die
für butter in amerika die jetzt
natürlich das ist ein gefundenes fressen
für diese waffen befürworte auch wenn
das ein tragischer vorfall ist denn sie
kann jetzt sagen es ist hier eine
heuchelei eine doppelmoral festzustellen
bei elektroden in der sich hier als
großer waffen beschränke aufspielt der
strengere regeln und kontrollen fordern
und gleichzeitig geben wie wie gesagt
zulässt dass auf seinem eigenen film set
solche zustände herrschen und der dort
seit juni hat hier sogar ein t shirt
jetzt verkaufen lassen mit dem berühmten
spruch ganz don quijote porto also
umgesetzt menschen waffen töten nicht
menschen töten und das hat ja
umformuliert auf waffen töten nicht alec
baldwin tötet menschen um das natürlich
halten viele für eine geschmacklosigkeit
aber auf der anderen seite ist es gibt
es menschen die das eben eher
gerechtfertigt finden als
gerechtfertigte kritik man darf auch
nicht vergessen dass alec baldwin
natürlich ein bisschen ein feind der
tramp familie ist denn er hat auf der in
der tv show saturday night live eben
donald trump jahrelang verkörpert und so
gesehen ist es natürlich eine fehde
zwischen den beiden und auch ein
ausdruck wie polarisiert amerika ist
diese diese spaltung der nation ist auch
hier nach dieser tragödie sichtbar in
amerika natürlich natürlich ist es
geschmacklos muss man sagen herbert
patricia aber es zeigt eben dass der
fokus immer stärker auf wind gerät
herbert vielen herzlichen dank für deine
einschätzung so weit die er ist es ja
auch gelungen mit einem absoluten
experten auf diesem gebiet zu sprechen
denn alle welt fragt sich was könnte
alec baldwin jetzt drohen wie geht es
jetzt für ihn weiter wir haben gerade
aufgezeichnet man kann durchaus sagen
man kann ihm durchaus unterstellen dass
eine gewisse mitschuld vorliegt an
diesen vorgängen zumindest ist er ist
produzent des films für viele dinge was
die am set passieren menschen die er
einstellt verantwortlich und darüber hat
unser kollege herbert bauernebel den wir
eben gerade gesehen haben mit einem der
berühmtesten us promi anwälte
gesprochener schon mal ein
sie haben erwähnt dass alec baldwin
strafrechtliche konsequenzen erwarten
könnten und er auch strafrechtliche
implikationen befürchten muss worauf
begründen sie diese annahme
es muss keine absicht sein aber er hat
jemand anderen in gefahr gebracht es gab
viele beschwerden über sicherheitslücken
von der kuh in bezug auf waffen am set
er hätte wissen sollen dass ein gewisses
risiko besteht zweitens hätte er wissen
müssen dass es risikoreiche handlungen
mit scharfen waffen gab er hat erst
offensichtlich eine unerfahrene waffen
meisterin engagiert es kommt noch hinzu
dass er um geld zu sparen ein team
gebucht hat das nicht abgestimmt war
normalerweise nutzt man aufeinander
abgestimmte filmcrews die die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen kennen und
einhalten um geld zu sparen nutzte er
ein team das nicht aufeinander
abgestimmt waren es wundert mich warum
jemand eine unerfahrene crew benutzt um
geld zu sparen ich denke er hat eine
gewisse mitschuld auch wenn er nicht
gewusst hat dass eine echte kugel in der
kammer war hätte er wissen müssen dass
es ein gewisses risiko wird davor mit
echter munition zu schießen
was könnte nun mögliche strafen seien
fahrlässige tötung fahrlässige tötung
bedeutet dass du dich selbst so
fahrlässig verhalten dass jemand bei
deiner handlung sterben könnte
erklären sie uns einmal wie die
juristischen schritte sind nachdem die
ermittlungen aufgenommen wurden vom
department santa fe wie geht es jetzt
weiter
ermittler untersuchen den fall mit dem
staatsanwalt und er entscheidet ob er
dem haftrichter vorgeführt wird denken
sie daran dass es auch politische gründe
geben könnte ihn nicht zu verurteilen er
ist ein großer name zweitens versucht
die filmindustrie in new mexico gerade
fuß zu fassen und sie wollen die leute
nicht verunsichern es würde einen großen
druck auf den staatsanwalt geben er ist
der produzent es ist sein job alles zu
überwachen während des filmes und
offensichtlich hat er das nicht gemacht
welche anderen schritte könnten noch
eingeleitet werden eine zivilrechtliche
klage und die des genoms geld
nein offensichtlich nicht denn sie ist
dann geht es nicht mehr nur ums geld es
gibt keine möglichkeit ein
zivilrechtliches verfahren einzuleiten
er ist der produzent es ist sein job er
braucht nicht die gleichen
qualifikationen wie seine mitarbeiter
ich bin mir sicher dass er sich keine
gedanken machen muss zivilrechtlich
bestraft zu werden da er versicherungen
hat aber selbst seine versicherung wird
ihn zu einem vergleich zwingen wollen es
muss sich geeinigt werden es ist eine
furchtbare verkettung von umständen sie
hätten wissen müssen dass sie einen
höheren sicherheitsstandard haben
sollten
ich ziehe hier noch keine schlüsse das
einzig schockierende ist das alles so
geheim gehalten wird das ist aber auch
nicht wirklich schockierend das ist ein
so ernst zu nehmendes verbrechen ein so
ernst zu nehmender vorfall und es sind
so viele prominente menschen involviert
sie wollen das also so lautlos wie
möglich austragen bis sie eine
entscheidung für
viele andere mehr in hollywood